Kalin and Zach were both in primary
school when Scotland's future was last
tested in a referendum you guys are
never going to agree are you now they're
young activists with divided identities
opposing views in a country once again
pondering the path ahead obviously we
will disagree however it's something
that is now made abundantly clear that
our nation is now no longer a nation of
equals and is no longer voluntary after
the next German election if we see
another decisive s p majority it's
possible but I think in the short term
definitely there will be no referendum
who should respect the result of 2014.
okay really good that was when David
Cameron and Alex salmond agreed to a
legally binding referendum when Scotland
eventually rejected Independence
here has been arguably paralyzed over
the Constitutional debate ever since
Nicholas sturgeon saying brexit led to
broken promises and her election wins
the argument to hold a second vote this
time Westminster says no and Supreme
Court judges were asked to determine
whether Hollywood can plow on without
Downing Street's permission
the Scottish Parliament does not have
the power to legislate for a referendum
on Scottish independence
and now a disappointed first Minister
triggers Plan B using the next general
election as a de facto referendum on the
question though people worry that we
don't get 50
percent massive gamble this is a huge
risk isn't it
I'm going to put this simply democracy
is always a risk if you want to look at
it like that because it depends on
persuading people of the point of view
you're putting forward I think that the
people of Scotland want us to be working
on fixing the major challenges that we
collectively face whether that's the
economy supporting the NHS or indeed
supporting Ukraine now is the time for
politicians to work together and that's
what this government will do
Dundee is a city that overwhelmingly
voted yes last time around now this is a
place where people are questioning what
comes next we can make our own decisions
we can make our own votes but quite
capable we're strong people Scottish
people and I think it should be left to
us
very angry to be honest with you I
thought I lived in a democracy
let's win our independence I might fail
to the Scotland you know it's possible
thank you all very much
almost every domestic issue here in
Scotland is seen through the prism of
true Independence or pro-union and
today's judgment however definitive
doesn't really move the conversation on
a whole lot what is clear is that both
campaigns will continue to Champion
their cause
battle lines have intensified as the
legal limbo ends